uh hi my name is JB Smoove hello and I
feel frustrated about being Conan
O'Brien's friend why would you be fresh
over it I feel over it that's not a good
word yeah I feel over this frustrated
wait a minute why did you go from
frustrated to over it is what it is
I've been through this before man
you know I tried to help you before but
you refuse to take the help when
see here's the language that's wrong
okay see here's the language
foreign
[Laughter]
right what's the wrong word what's the
bad word it is need yeah you ain't too
needy man well we've been through this
we talked about at the top of the show
uh you know I focus on the one gentleman
who doesn't want to listen to the
podcast and that's all I can think and
yes I'm to get JB so you see his thing
you're trying to find a frame yeah this
is the wrong way to do it man
you got to take a friend
wait a minute
taking a very creepy turn you two busy
trying to find a friend you need
you like that song is that a good is
that a good coding impression yeah yeah
it is it's perfect it's spot on that's
okay
baby girl you'd like to try one
I need a friend
requests
right now and I can't decide which one I
am
so you think it's too needy it's too
needy it's too needy you you are too
busy trying to find a friend when you
should be taking a friend when you see
again that's a very good chloroform
you know a group of people having a
great time they all laughing and joking
around they're having a ball
you go over there and take the one you
want
here's what it's like you watch those
old movies and and maybe in those ball
dresses and they're dancing in the
middle of a floor it is a big ball go a
ball and people have ladies have a long
ass dress on everybody stepping on that
[ __ ] it's a long ass dressing and we all
know
[Music]
[Laughter]
for a little while and you proceed to
dance with that [ __ ] yeah
this is a metaphor I understand of
course it is you want me to
metaphorically tap on someone's
shoulders say may I cut in no no no no
no no no no no no no no that's what
you're saying no listening no you
physically touch that [ __ ] you
tap his [ __ ] shoulder oh you want me
to do a [ __ ] middle finger like
you mind if I cut the [ __ ] in and you
proceed to take them
your [ __ ] head is up you long and
lean yeah your back can be taunted like
this and you [ __ ] hold that you hold
your head up proudly yeah and you hold a
conversation with this [ __ ] and
find out if he fits into your [ __ ]
square and he's a [ __ ] Circle you
gotta find out if it's gonna work okay
you take that friend okay you rely you
you tell him things that you don't have
you everything
you take that friend you steal that
friend away see now you're in control
yeah you're in control of the Friendship
therefore you are no longer
needy yeah okay okay let's take it easy
on those you know yeah I I hear what
you're saying I should be a little more
I think have a little self-esteem maybe
have a little confidence and and it
shouldn't be Conor O'Brien needs a
friend Conan O'Brien takes a friend
takes a friend yeah it changes the whole
dynamic what do you think I do think the
wording is a little problematic the
taking part I'm still confused about I
know you tap someone on the shoulder and
then you just become their friend but I
think that I'm a little confused about
maybe a little bit yeah a little
frightened too it's a little yeah
remember there was a Friday the 13th
movie Jason Takes Manhattan it kind of
feels like that well no no one remembers
that movie
wow
[Laughter]
um yeah no I don't remember that but I
understand what you said it can be you
know in this era you want to make sure
that there's uh that you know that the
other person's interested in being my
friend that's all no look
I'm not saying no no I'm not saying put
that person in a choke hold I'm saying
use your charisma Charisma all this [ __ ]
that's cool about you yeah you see them
up they're [ __ ] You're gonna laugh in
their ass off you saying to yourself I
would love to be in that circle of
friends I bet they have a good time all
the [ __ ] time look at look at them ah
they got history and loving each other
look at that you just you just nuzzle
your ass up in there now you nuzzle
nothing
I gotta use my face to sort of just like
a wedge and wedge in there
role play this where the three of us are
having a conversation and you could try
it out oh my God I would love to try
that all right let's try you guys are
having a good
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hold on
you're right I went in I came in too
strong